welcome to the ask evan show
episode 9. let's get to your questions i
am excited oh before that
i have a special guest so we've had this
whole orchid no orchid
debate fiasco today joining me are
nina's
minion cupcakes so they're cupcakes with
minions on it so
i wonder what you think about the minion
cupcakes and if you have a challenge
for nina to make something else that
should be here
leave it in the comments below and she
might
have to do it which would be a fun
challenge so we'll see
okay let's go episode nine first
question comes from olga from my
newsletter list love you guys
writes in to say that she has a book
and she says perhaps you can show me
ways to promote a book when most of
today's talk shows just want laughter
jokes and discussion of
movies they're not eager to discuss why
history repeats itself and why no matter
how hard some people tried the word was
filled with violence and despair
this is a great question and the very
first thing you need to do is change
your mindset because now you've created
this world for yourself
telling yourself that this is all people
want to talk about and the world is
against me and so i'm not going to be
successful hey
there's people who care about this stuff
how did oprah become so successful was
it by talking about violence and war
and and just movies and jokes no she
tried to touch on real things that
people cared about
there are people who care about this
stuff and the first thing you need to do
is take accountability
this isn't this isn't i'm not going to
sell my book
because nobody cares about this topic
right it's i'm going to find the people
i'm going to take personal
responsibility personal accountability
and find the people who care
this is part of my message you know i
don't talk about a lot of jokes i'm
maybe i'm not
funny enough guy uh i don't talk about
violence i don't try to put people down
and talk about celebrities all the time
you know the stuff that i put out i try
to make sure it's meaningful stuff that
people care about
you know i believe entrepreneurs to
change the world and so that's what i'm
here it's my mission to to put out there
and i've been covered in tons of media
and so the way to start is to make a
list
find the the bloggers the magazine
editors the newspaper editors the
youtube video
people don't just limit yourself to
traditional media go
online media there's a lot of youtube
people who are awesome who can help
spread this message really quickly for
you
better than a lot of the people in
traditional media find those people
make a list and reach out to them and
give them a story
don't just say hey i've got this new
book that i'm trying to promote because
nobody cares about that
everybody's got a book they're trying to
promote tell me about what it's about
tell me about
why history repeats itself tell me about
the point of this book well you know
what are you standing for
what positive impact is your book gonna
make what's the big problem in the world
that you're trying to help solve
lead with something like that to a
targeted audience you know if you if
this book was about entrepreneurship
and how entrepreneurs are heroes and how
entrepreneurs are the people are going
to change the world
you say that to me i'm interested i want
to learn more i might have you on my
channel i might put you in my newsletter
right i care about that stuff
and so you just need to find the people
who are like me but for your market
but don't don't don't give up don't sit
there and think
nobody cares about this stuff because as
long as you create that reality for
yourself that's the world you're gonna
live in and your book's never gonna get
anywhere
people want to say yes people care about
this stuff you just have to find the
influencers
they exist they want to hear from you so
reach out to them
okay next up dennis another newsletter
reader writes in to say
it's true i wake up this early in the
morning to do something that i don't
like but what else
is there for me i don't have enough
capital to start my own business not
enough salary support my desire of
freedom
where should i run to evan yes i have
great ideas on how to grow economically
but these tough handles in life can
allow me to reach there
help me to realize my dream brother
dennis this is another one okay this is
a mindset thing
as long as you're telling yourself that
you know you don't have the resource to
do it you don't have the job to do it
you don't have savings to do it the
economy won't let you do it
some of the greatest businesses ever
were started in recessionary time
when the economy wasn't great were
started by people who
who had nothing had zero income had had
no savings
had no education had no resources look
at famous entrepreneurs look at the
entrepreneurs you respect
look at where they started from look at
how they started look at the conditions
that they started in
they didn't start with everything handed
to them that's not how successful
entrepreneurs
are created so you have to
make up your mind that i'm going to be a
successful entrepreneur
and start chasing your dream and if you
have a job
where you're not learning anything that
you hate doing then the next step
is to go actually get a job from
somebody who you can learn from somebody
who you can
who they can be your mentor who can
teach you about a certain business if
you're going to work
you're not working for money you're
working to learn and start something on
the side
you have half an hour every day to make
your dream happen half an hour you can
find half an hour
every single day to move your business
forward if you don't have half an hour
then you don't deserve to have the life
of your dreams if you're not willing to
put in
half an hour at least every single day
to move your business forward
to to move closer to this ideal life
that you want if you don't really put in
at least that amount of effort
then then you don't deserve it and
and this is such an important question
because so many entrepreneurs or want to
be entrepreneurs
tell themselves all these same excuses
right i don't have enough money i don't
have enough savings the economy is
really bad you know
or they tell themselves other things
right i had i had the guy
from a previous episode talk about how
he was gay and because he's gay he's not
going to be able to be a successful
entrepreneur
some people think because they're old or
they're young or they're a woman
or they're they're you know not from
america or they have an accent whatever
it is like we find these excuses
that hold us back and it's just a
limiting personal belief none of that
stuff matters
you can build a successful business from
nothing i did a profile
not so long ago christine let's put that
up of of uh tom monaghan who founded
domino's pizza he had nothing
and he turned it into domino's pizza
which became
an international franchise made him
millions of dollars
it's possible it's it's almost normal
for
these highly successful entrepreneurs to
come from absolutely nothing
so your game plan you start by finding a
job that supports you that you like a
little bit more where you're learning
from and you're not just
punching a paycheck and waiting to you
know waiting for evenings and weekends
to come two you're starting your
business on the side
something half an hour every day you get
home half an hour every day you're
working away it's something to grow your
business
and three start to get some inspiration
you know
find entrepreneurs that you look up to
who started from nothing
and that you can say hey they did it so
i can do it too
create that list get inspired by their
stories because you need to break out of
that mindset
that's holding you back saying that i
will never be successful because of xyz
you can be successful it's totally in
your hands
you gotta change your mindset start to
believe
okay next is gamal another newsletter
reader we gotta we got a lot of news
that are loved today
right soon to say is the owner of my
business they have a right to log into
my
company email and see all my
correspondence with suppliers as well as
clients or not
i'm talking about is that a professional
way to do things or not your your reply
is highly appreciated thanks kamal
so in short typically yes you know if
it's company
the company owns the email the company
has access to it you need to expect that
they have potential access to your email
uh that's why a lot of people have uh
their own personal email and if they're
gonna send something that they
they're worried that their boss might
see the word that might not look good
they're worried that you know they don't
want people to find out about then they
put under their personal account
so in short yeah they they have the
right to have access to it typically
is it professional or not just depends
on the company you know
i i could go in and look at all of the
emails that everybody on my team
has sent do i care no i don't care i
mean
i'd rather hire people who who i trust
who would do a good job who i don't need
to micromanage right and if you feel
like
you are being micromanager there's no
trust at the business that people are
you know looking everything that you're
saying and they're judging you and it's
holding you back
doesn't let you focus on what you know
what you really want to do
then leave you know don't put up with
that have some respect
right you have to have standards what
you will and will not
expect in your life and and people will
will live up to those standards right if
you have no standards for yourself then
people will walk all over you
where if you raise your standards you
see this is this is who i am
i have self-respect this is what i will
and will not respect
then people have to play by those rules
and that may mean going to a company
that will respect you more and won't
dive into your emails
sounds like you're kind of pissed off
about it and so that's the case
then go find a job that better supports
you or better yet
start your own business friend and start
making a huge impact on the world
that's what i'm talking about believe
next up
darius one of my youtube viewers love
all you guys on youtube
i thought it was too late for me to
start a business i'm 21
still don't know how or what to do sign
darius
bro man 21 you are you still got tons of
time ahead of you
there are so many entrepreneurs who who
don't even get started till they're in
their 50s or 60s and still go on
to create huge companies and have a
major impact on the world
21 i feel the frustration you know you
want to
you want to move on you want to get
started you want to feel like you're
having an impact you want to do
something with your life and there's
nothing more frustrating
than than not knowing what to do
right to wake up and not know what to do
or go to some job that you hate
not feeling like you're you're
leveraging your skills or having an
impact or learning
the best thing that i could advise you
to do
is start to explore just
try stuff out see what you like
jump it's okay to jump from one thing to
another to another until you find
something that you start to fall in love
with
because most people do the opposite most
people take take the safe advice
the the proper thing to do is you know
go put on a suit and tie go get this job
because you
went to school for this type of career
and
and then you end up in this career that
you hate that you don't look forward to
every day you're driving to work and
you're you like it less and less and
less and
your mind starts to numb and you just
can't wait to go home and
and and you know live for that evening
and so i don't think that's a smart
thing to do people to say that's a smart
thing to do i don't think that's a smart
thing to do at all i think your better
bet
is to try something out and if it
doesn't work try something else and try
something else and try something else
until you find something that you fall
in love with
and and it may not look great on the
resume but you're going to end up at the
end of your life looking back and saying
yeah i mean i had i maybe spent two
years wandering
but i ended up finding something that i
love and now i'm having a huge impact
and so just don't be afraid don't be
afraid to reach out and try things and
actually go out
and start doing stuff you know if you're
thinking about starting the business try
starting a business
if you're thinking about learning how to
be a cook go try to learn how to be a
cook
and if you don't like it stop as soon as
you stop liking it stop
but if you start falling in love with it
dive deep into it explore
and an opportunity will present itself
my my
some of my favorite advice from steve
jobs is
as with all matters of the heart you'll
know when you find it
so keep searching don't lose hope
don't lose courage take action you are
definitely not too late
at 21. and report back man i know
because it can be hard i know you're
frustrated
but report back and let us know how
you're doing last question of the day
comes from
meyron from my youtube channel writes in
to say evan love the videos
i really feel inspired by them you've
made a great job sharing your valuable
principles i have a question for you i'm
a believer
i love that who has 20 years old i'm
still in college my dream is to build a
company and develop products that make
people's lives easier what do you advise
me to do to get my goal work for some
company get experience before i open my
own business
or should i open my own business without
experience this is a fantastic question
and i would say embrace the genius of
the and
instead of thinking you can do this or
do this do both of them together
because if you want to have a big impact
okay you want to make a real difference
in the world you want to make a lot of
money
it's going to come from providing value
and a lot of times when people start a
business
and have zero experience they can't
provide the value right you have to be
able to
give people value if you don't know what
you're doing yet then you can't
provide people that value and so you can
struggle along struggle along try to
find your way
and slowly start increasing your value
or you can learn from somebody else
who's doing exactly what you want to do
and they can help shortcut your path so
i would say go find a company
who's in your space who i don't know
what you want to do find that company
who has 10 employees or less
where you can jump in and that's the
company that you eventually want to
build up to
work as closely to the entrepreneur
founder as possible get involved in as
many projects as possible don't just try
to
don't just be refined by like one little
task one
one set part of the business
entrepreneurs need help and if they see
that you are
aggressive and you are you're dedicated
and you put in the time and you want to
learn
they'll give you projects go to them and
say hey how can i help make this company
better and they'll give you more
projects so you're learning right you're
soaking up that experience you're making
mistakes
on somebody else's dime you're gaining
connections you're learning the industry
you're
you're understanding how to add more
value to customers at the same time you
start on the side
you start your own thing on the side you
start part-time
if it's evenings weekends whatever it is
you start
even if it's for free just to build up
your roster get some experience again
the whole thing is i'm trying to
get value right i'm trying to be able to
understand how to provide value to these
customers
and as you build up you can start
charging start charging more start
charging more
and eventually get to the point where
you're not learning as much from this
company anymore
you you learn like this and then you
start to plateau
right and hopefully your company is
starting to grow as well
and that's that's the flip point right
you're not learning as much from the
company anymore
your own business starting to make some
money you could jump to go
full time into your business so that's
what i recommend don't think of it as
this or this
combine them both together get the job
start working on your business at the
same time and start
going out giving value to customers and
making an impact that wraps up another
edition of the ask evan show thank you
guys so much for your questions if you
guys have further ones leave it in the
comments below
and i'll make a video reply for you
continue to believe
and if you like this video you want to
see more just like it subscribe to the
channel
and don't forget to comment
on these minion cupcakes nina's here
nina
hi here's nina so i took out the orchid
okay and you put my cupcakes in there
yeah
what do you think well so here's what i
said okay
i said uh that you made these obviously
and then i i challenged them to come up
with something else
that you should make
then you didn't challenge them you
challenged me well i challenge them to
challenge you
so i feel like it's a good it's a good
challenge so leave a comment
as to what you think nina should make
next beyond the minion cupcakes
and and we'll see if she accepts your
challenge the challenge
maybe see that's it bye
which one should i eat eat the blue one
the blue one why the blue one
because this is the most advanced it's
the ugliest one how come you're
my favorite this one
how many six oh so many
if you want to see more great content to
keep you inspired
motivated and believing check out my
newsletter in the link below